ينضم الينا مجددا من تونس العاصمه مراسل
فرانس 24 نور الدين الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات اكدت الغاء كليا
وجزئيا للنتائج بعدد من الدوائر
الانتخابيه على خلفيه ارتكاب مخالفات هل
مزيد من التفاصيل
الانتخابات في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي مازال
متواصل الى حدود هذه اللحظه هو اكد انه تم
الغاء جزئيا وكليا لنتائج سبعه مترشحين في
عدد بناء الدوائر بحسب المعطيات التي
قدمها فان هذا الغاء الجزئي والكلي ياتي
على خلفيه ارتكاب عدد من مخالفات
الانتخابيه التي ترتقي الى مستوى الجريمه
الانتخابيه سواء خلال الحمله الانتخابيه
او خلال فتره الصمت او خلال فتره الاختراع
هذه هذه الغابه في الحقيقه هو موزع
الكل موزع على اربع دوائر دائره بمحافظه
منزرت ايضا مدينه سليمان من محافظه قنا
الى جانب ضحيه سيدي ابو سعيد من تونس
العاصمه وايضا تونس اثنين اما فيما يتعلق
الجزء لعدد بناء المترشحين فانه بمحافظه
نزار بمدينه مطر وايضا في محافظه بازار ثم
في مدينه اكثر من مدينه هؤلاء تم فالجزئي
والكلي لنتائجهم المقصود بالالغاء الكلي
هو الغاء كافه النتائج التي تحصلوا عليها
في كافه مراكز الاقتراع التي تاتي تاتي
تحت الدائره الانتخابيه اما المقصود
بالالغاء الجزئي فانه الغاء النتائج فقط
في احد مراكز الاقتراب التي تاكد انه تم
ارتكاب فيه جرائم انتخابيه هذه الجرائم
بحسب رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات فان تراه واحد اما بين تقديم
همم مساعدات ماليه او استعمال العالم
التونسي او حتى في مستوى الخطاب هناك خطاب
وصفه رئيس الهيئه بانه خطاب كراهيه وتحرير
وهذا يعد ويزمنا الجرائم الانتخابيه لذلك
تمت عمليه الغاء الجزء الكليه هو بالاضافه
الى هذه العمليه همم هو ايضا اكد ان نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات شهدت ارتفاعا خاصه
بعد غلق كافه مراكز القراءه وبالتالي اصبح
عدد الذين يشاركوا في العمليه الانتخابيه
نحو العيون و25,000 اي بنسبه 11.2 في
الايه 22% نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس
العاصمه مراسل فرانس 24